hey Luke dominate here with the outdoor
boys YouTube channel and we're going to
show you how to put together this
awesome survival axe
[Music]
all right me and the boys we're out here
in the woods and cold and we're gonna
demonstrate this awesome survival act
set up and if you are familiar with axes
you may recognize this as a fist car axe
this is a great off-the-shelf backs not
too expensive it's got a composite
handle and the great thing about these
handles is they're super light they
never break and the axe head will never
come off I've owned one of these for
about 25 years thing is just taking all
the abuse I can dish out does great and
they're light too what I'm gonna do is
show you how to take one of these fist
car axes and turn them into an awesome
survival kit all right you guys may be
thinking sure this is an ice axe but why
is it a survival axe so let me show you
the secret the key is that the handle is
hollow so boom let me show you what we
got Tommy's demonstrating one of the
first items in the kit got a signal
whistle okay like this the nice thing
about these whistles is if you're in a
survival situation screaming will just
tire you out and ruin your voice you
need to signal for help this whistles
super loud and it won't ruin your voice
doing it okay you can just sit there and
you can just go and blow on this thing
all night long
and won't tire you out the next thing we
got is a survival blanket in here guys
you guys cold yes let's bust this out
here
it's called the space blanket
now these space blankets are designed to
reflect your body heat up but they serve
a lot of functions it's a tarp it's a
very very lightweight tarp right now
it's serving as an awesome windbreak
doesn't it nice not have that cold wind
on you anymore if it's raining this can
keep the rain off you and you can wrap
up in it also if you run out of food you
can make tin foil dinners out of the
children the next item in here is a
gallon size ziploc bag with a bunch of
aqua tabs in it enough to treat two
gallons of water this stuff kills
bacteria and viruses and doesn't have
the funky taste of iodine so you can
fill the bag up with the water there's a
one gallon bag so you put five tablets
in there let it sit for 30 minutes and
then you've got a gallon of drinking
water all right here's another item in
my survival kit the 210 lights so you
can see here you got a very powerful LED
pen light that runs off of two triple A
batteries so you can see I've wrapped
the pen light and some 20-pound spider
wire braid and three Eagle Claw bait
hooks there priests nailed up so I've
got fishing lines and fishing hooks and
also in the axe handle are some LED
split shot so that's nice little fishing
kit takes up almost no space and weight
so it's a real easy freebie item to
throw in there also it's important in
survival situations like this to have a
lot of videos downloaded onto your phone
so the kids don't kill each other here
you guys don't watch Captain Underpants
all right guys let me show you the next
items flint and steel for making fire
and I've got a little ziploc bag with
some cotton balls soaked in Vaseline as
a fire starter great for making a fire
in a hurry like now it's really cold
baby you've fallen in the water and you
need to get warm in a hurry works really
great
[Music]
another thing you'll notice about this
accident in paracord this is 550
paracord about a little under 30 feet of
it and it's wrapped around the handle in
a quick deploy method using a chain sit
at none now when I say quick deploy what
I mean is that you can take it off very
quickly all you have to do is undo this
bottom knot and then the whole thing
unravels let me show you all you got to
do is just undo this and then you just
pull this out
[Music]
there you go so there you go about 27
feet of paracord if you did the entire
length of the handle you could probably
get somewhere between 50 to 60 feet and
of course paracord is awesome you can
take that space blanket and the paracord
and build a primitive shelter something
to keep the rain off yeah to help
reflect the heat of your campfire on you
while you sleep a lot of things you can
do with paracord the sheath on this axe
is really snazzy it's plastic it's got
this handle on there very durable don't
need to worry about getting wet you go
and just turn this thing like so and
comes right out but you need a sheath
because this thing is very sharp
I love these Fisker axes in part because
they're so light this axe right here is
a chopping axe not a hatchet but it
weighs about the same as a wood handled
hatchet but they're razor sharp and they
work very well the serious axe
Hey look I could hear a plane oh he
didn't hear my whistle space blanket
also works great for people to be able
to see you alright guys let me show you
a little bit more details about this axe
and what goes on inside it and how to
pack it up alright you can see down the
handle here there's that yellow piece of
string that I use to pull everything out
and I've just taped it with a little bit
of painters tape to the inside of a
handle it's not necessary but it just
makes it look nice
can't see the string flapping out of the
handle alright just reach in here pop
off the tape grab this piece of string
start pulling so when you're packing
this ax handle the first thing is make
sure your string is really strong I'm
using 200 pound test line braid because
if the string breaks all your stuff is
stuck down in the handle and good luck
getting it out so that's important
secondly what you want to do is you want
to attach the string to whatever goes on
the very bottom and you want what's on
the bottom to be something tough once
again if you pull it and you break the
item off then your everything's stuck in
the handle so iitai attached it to both
the whistle and to the flint and steel
to get the gallon-sized ziplocks bag to
fit you've got to roll it up bottom to
top and then I've got in here 10 of
these aqua tabs and you've got to put
those in this way getting this face
blanket to fit you really have to
compress it tight and then use these
little twisty ties from a sandwich bag
to keep it from getting off skill want
this on you to get it to all fit in the
handle you're gonna need a ramrod of
some type I got this little piece of
wood dowel to load up the axe the first
thing you're gonna want to do is
put it on the ground like this and step
through the handle and lock it in place
the first thing you do is wrap the bag
with the cotton balls around the Flint
and you're going to take the steel and
the whistle and the steel and the
whistle go down first they should just
drop down in there and then put the
steel in and it's a little bit snugger
so use the ramrod put it all the way
down squish it down there nice and tight
then put the flashlight in and put it
button side down so that if you
accidentally turn it on you can see the
lights on that should just drop in split
shot goes in and then just look make
sure the split shots not on top of the
the lens take these two together and use
the ramrod and the bag of the space
blanket are about an inch half an inch
from the end of the handle so you can
see them right there put the string in
there and just use a little bit of
painters tape and there you go you're
off to the races alright next let me
show you how to wrap the axe handle and
paracord the paracord wrap is very
ergonomic it feels great in the hand and
it doesn't slide around a ton if you do
it really tight it's on there very
secure it's super easy to do it's just a
chain Sinnott not let me show you how to
do it to start the wrap place the Flint
in the hole in the bottom of the handle
and take the working end and wrap it
around the Flint then pin it with your
hands and take the working end wrap it
around the back of the axe make a bite
and then form a bite on the other side
with the working end and put the second
bite through the first bite and once
you've done that tighten it up by
pulling the top of the bite then repeat
the process wrapping the working end
behind the axe forming a second bite and
placing the second bite through the
first bite and tightening it up this is
the chain Sinnott not simply taking one
loop and placing it through another loop
in a series and when it's done right it
makes this awesome pattern all the
down the handle and you're just feeding
one loop through a second loop and then
forming a new loop and putting it
through the second loop and just doing
it over and over and over again and you
do this until you get to the very end
then you take the line and you don't
form a loop you simply feed the tag in
through a loop tighten it up and then
feed it through the loop at the very
bottom of the handle once that's tight
you take a pair of pliers and grab the
tag in at the top of your wrap
pull it tight and that'll tuck the knot
into the wrap and tighten the whole
thing up I like to put a little loop on
the end of my tag end and it looks
gorgeous and it's a really simple knot
once you get the hang of it well guys I
hope you enjoyed this video about my
survival kit if you'd like to make this
survival kit at home I'm gonna put a
link in the description to all the
different items and products I put into
my kit so you can make it at home a rate
we hope you enjoyed this thanks for
watching thanks for watching we hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boy's YouTube channel don't forget to
click Subscribe we put out new videos
every week and don't forget to hit that
Bell button so you'll get notified when
we put out another great video